So yesterday, a day before presiding over
a joint session of Congress to confirm the
victory of Joe Biden as the next president
of the United States, Joe Biden, Mike Pence,
rather, Vice Vice President Mike Pence met
with Donald Trump and reportedly told him,
I can't overturn the election results.
Donald Trump has been increasingly pointing
to Mike Pence, saying, we've got to count
on Mike Pence.
Mike Pence has to come through for us.
And that's code for figure out a way to steal
an election that we actually didn't win.
And The New York Times is now reporting that
Mike Pence, quote, tried to lower the president's
expectations while seeking ways to mollify
him.
This is an article by Anthony Carney and Maggie
Haberman where they say Vice President Mike
Pence told Trump on Tuesday that he didn't
believe he had the power to block congressional
certification of Joe Biden's win in the presidential
election, which is true, he doesn't.
Despite Trump's baseless insistence that he
did and this is according to multiple people
briefed on the content of the conversation.
This took place during the weekly lunch that
Mike Pence has with Donald Trump.
And this was just hours after Trump started
publicly pressuring Mike Pence to essentially
steal the election for him.
I mean, we have to call things what they are
and these euphemisms about making sure all
legal votes are counted.
We have the election results in every state.
Those results have been certified.
The electors have been certified their votes.
And today and it may be happening as we speak,
it may be done by the time you listen to today's
show or watch this clip.
The joint session of the House and Senate
is counting those votes.
Trump tweeted, The president has the power
to reject fraudulently chosen electors.
And, of course, it is not true that there
were fraudulently chosen electors.
None of this is true.
And most importantly, Mike Pence cannot alter
the results.
Mike Pence can hear objections from senators
and members of the House, which we expect
to hear.
There can be debate about that.
We heard that Tim Scott and James Inhofe to
radical right senators are saying that they
will not be participating in these attempts
to undermine the results.
But reportedly 11 or 12 Republican senators
are going to.
So there's a few different aspects to this.
Number one, January 20th really couldn't get
here any faster.
We're down to exactly two weeks, two weeks
to the day.
Joe Biden will be getting sworn in and Trump
will be we don't know where.
And I'll talk actually about that a little
bit later.
I would love to have been a fly on the wall
during the conversation where Pence is explaining
to Trump, I can't just alter the results.
I can't just declare ourselves.
I can't declare you and I the winners.
I just can't do it.
How is Trump reacting during that conversation?
Was he furious?
Was he resigned?
Was he sad?
Was he mopey? Trump And then even after this
conversation took place where Mike Pence told
Trump, I can't do the thing you want me to
do, Trump insisted on Twitter that he can
again Trump tweeting, We looked at this tweet
earlier.
If Vice President Mike Pence comes through
for us, we will win the presidency.
Many states want to decertify the mistake
they made in certifying incorrect and even
fraudulent numbers in a process not approved
by their state legislatures, which it must
be.
Mike can send it back and he can't.
So let's do kind of a gut check.
Consider how insane it is that this is something
that happened.
The president is told by the vice president,
I can't steal the election.
And it's newsworthy.
It is newsworthy because that is exactly what
the president wants the vice president to
do.
Things are so nutty that it is actually noteworthy
that a vice president had to sit the president
down and talk to him like a big boy and say,
I can't steal the election for you.
Now, as a reminder, the line of reasoning
that it takes to assume Mike Pence can do
this is that Mike Pence, as the presiding
officer of this joint session to count electoral
votes, can say, I am going to ignore.
Or certain electoral votes as decided by the
states.
Oh, the Pennsylvania electoral vote, I'm going
to ignore them.
We're not going to count those.
And there's this alternate slate of electors,
which is just random people.
It's not there's nothing legally binding.
I'm going to accept as an alternate slate
of electors these 20 Republicans who showed
up and did something of no legally binding
importance and said we vote for Trump.
Pence doesn't have the power to do that.
And a number of interesting procedural and
congressional law experts over the last few
days have given interviews to that effect.
I'm not bothering to play them because I think
most of my audience understands that Trump's
dying words really may be we totally won Georgia.
We totally won Pennsylvania in 2020.
He may repeat that to his dying day, but Trump's
leaving in two weeks.
And the concern, of course, is how are
the Trump cultists going to react